i want to talk about antebellum because
i called it a sort of a psychological
thriller this
is a fascinating idea for a movie
disturbing on so many levels
but really beautifully done and we want
to show a clip of it but i want to make
sure i don't give away too much because
there's so many twists and turns in
antebellum
people have to see it they got to watch
it but i want to make sure that we don't
tell
too much so i want to turn it over to
you what can you tell us about
antebellum
that uh you think i mean first of all it
feels like
very of the moment and also just a very
just a powerful story
yeah i mean i can't really say much
without completely
uh taking away like the most exciting
part of the movie
which is this i think like a genre
bending
film and i think that
you get lost in each act which is really
cool you think you're watching one movie
and it turns into another and
i think that's important for people to
know before
they watch it because it it really is
like this
it's a storytelling experience you know
yeah it really
is we have a clip here anything you want
to tell us about the clip before we show
it
um no good okay i mean
i actually think that's fair because i i
don't this is such an interesting movie
and i'm
i mean it's in the best way i think the
less said the better i really think
people should
i think so too all right let's take
let's take a look at this clip from
antebellum
cool i know you
and i know that you are my only way out
of here
i need you to listen to me
you have to keep quiet these white
people won't kill you you think being
quiet is being strong huh
what has that ever gotten us all right
i'm excited uh antibillum is available
at home on demand and it's available
this friday and people
watch this it's really fantastic kirsty
i love talking to you i really do
you are i love talking to you thank you
for having me on and always being so
nice to me i really do appreciate you
be safe uh continue to take care of
yourself and i can't wait to see you in
person sometime soon
yeah that'd be nice um thank you so much
thank you kersey take care